Sabemos que la rusia de Vladimir Putin
es una fuente inagotable de
controversias, y que en YouTube es
siempre uno de los temas más calientes.
De hecho cada vez que hemos sacado el
tema en VisualPolitik siempre hemos
recibido una avalancha de comentarios y
mensajes muy polarizados.
Muchos nos han acusado de ser anti-Putin
y otros de justo todo lo contrario
lo cierto es que ni lo uno ni
lo otro.
Hemos hablado ya en diferentes vídeos
de muchos aspectos de este
gigantesco país. Pues bien, en este vídeo
queremos realizar una radiografía sobre
las políticas económicas de Putin,
porque amigos,
Rusia se encuentra en una auténtica
encrucijada.
Aunque nos pueda sorprender, cuando
el 1 de enero del año 2000, Putin asumió
la Presidencia de Rusia, no parecía
existir hostilidad alguna hacia Estados
Unidos, la unión europea o el resto de
lo que podemos denominar como el
"bando occidental".
De hecho, en su primera entrevista para
la BBC, Putin afirmó lo siguiente:
A tenor de los
acontecimientos vividos, parece difícil
de creer.
Sin embargo ésta fue una posición que
sobrevivió bastante tiempo. Y no sólo
ocurría esto en lo referente a la
política internacional,
el aperturismo del primer gobierno de
Putin se observa también en su
política económica.
Por ejemplo, a los pocos meses de ser
Presidente, Putin nombró como Ministro
de Economía y Comercio a un economista
liberal, a German Gref, el cual elaboró
un programa económico que se
estructuraba, atentos, bajo dos ideas
principales:
1. la primacía del individuo sobre el
estado y 2.la necesidad aprovechar los
altos precios del petróleo para
realizar reformas pro mercado.
En la misma línea, Putin también
contrató como su consejero económico
principal a Andrei Illarionov, un
economista, también liberal, que forma
parte del CATO Institute. Para los que no
lo conozcáis, un Think Tank liberal con
sede en Washington.
Ya os podeis hacer una idea: economistas y reformas
pro mercado, aperturismo.... en los primeros
años todo apuntaba a que Rusia estaba
transitando de forma definitiva
hacia el club de las potencias occidentales.
Bueno, es que incluso hubo quien puso
sobre la mesa una posible adhesión de
Rusia a la Unión Europea ¡cómo
cambian los tiempos!
El resultado de todo ello fue más que
exitoso. Durante los primeros ocho años
del gobierno de Putin, la economía rusa
creció una media del 7% anual,
la estabilidad y las reformas
impulsarán con fuerza la inversión y
los capitales internacionales
prácticamente llovían sobre el
país.
Sin embargo, junto a esta tendencia, también
se empezaron a percibir ciertas sombras:
Putin desencadenó al poco de acceder al
gobierno una guerra contra la
oligarquía que controlaba muchas
de las grandes corporaciones rusas.
Vamos a ver, no es que esos oligarcas
fueran precisamente empresarios limpios.
La mayor parte de ellos utilizaron
métodos más que cuestionables como el
soborno, para hacerse a precios de ganga
con muchos de los activos de la antigua
Unión Soviética.
- "Algunos de ellos
llegaron a mi oficina cuando Yeltsin
dijo que iba a presentar mi candidatura
y me dijeron: ¿sabe usted que aquí
nunca va a ser presidente? Yo dije, ya
veremos". Pero es que las prácticas de
Putin para conseguir su lealtad ocpara
quitarse de en medio a quienes no se
subordinaran a él, tampoco fueron
precisamente ortodoxas.
El mejor ejemplo es el caso de Mijaíl
Jodorkovski, el propietario de Yukos, la
mayor petrolera del país, y que era
considerado por aquel entonces como la
persona más rica de Rusia. Pues bien,
Jodorkovski, creyéndose intocable
comenzó a financiar a partidos
políticos de la oposición ¿el resultado?
En octubre 2003, en vísperas de las
elecciones parlamentarias, fue detenido por
una unidad especial de los servicios
secretos, condenado a nueve años de
cárcel y además el estado ruso le
expropió su empresa y la mayor parte de
su fortuna.
Amnistía Internacional lo ha
considerado siempre como una condena
política. -"El tribunal permanente de
arbitraje de la Haya ha condenado a
Rusia a indemnizar con 40.000 millones
de euros a empresas del que fuera el
hombre más rico de Rusia, Mijaíl
Jordorkovski".
En 2005, Andrei Illarionov, el economista contratado
como Consejero Económico Principal,
dimitió, e hizo la siguiente
afirmación:
Así transcurrieron las cosas, hasta que
en 2008 la crisis internacional le
asestó un duro golpe a la economía
rusa, que en pocos meses se desplomó 10
por ciento.
A partir de ese momento todo cambió: el
estado cogió el testigo y en los años
siguientes
utilizó los ingentes recursos
procedentes del boom petrolero y las
materias primas para incrementar el
gasto público, modernizar el ejército y
consolidar un modelo de estado muy
paternalista. Entre 2009 y 2014 el peso
del estado en la economía se duplicó,
pasando del 35% al 70%.
Además, Putin a cabo en la práctica con
el federalismo y las libertades civiles
comenzaron a sufrir.
En 2012, ante siquiera que los precios
del petróleo comenzaron a caer, la
economía rusa ya dio muestras de
debilidad y comenzó a desacelerarse.
La elevada dependencia del petróleo,
la falta de competencia, su pobre
integración en el comercio
internacional o la falta de seguridad
jurídica, fueron algunas de las causas
de su estancamiento, y claro cuando en
2014 los precios del petróleo y las
materias primas se vinieron abajo,
la economía rusa siguió  el mismo camino.
- "En las dos primeras semanas de enero, el
precio del crudo bajó hasta un 20%,
llegando a mínimos históricos".
un castigo que, además, se vio reforzado con
las sanciones impuestas por occidente
tras la crisis de Ucrania y la anexión
rusa de Crimea. -"Consenso para renovar las
sanciones a Rusia, los embajadores
europeos se han puesto de acuerdo para
prolongar seis meses más, hasta el 31 de
enero de 2017,
las sanciones económicas a Rusia".
El resultado es que la economía rusa
lleva el recesión más de 20 meses, y el
número de personas bajo el umbral de la
pobreza creció sólo en 2015 en más
de tres millones de personas hasta
alcanzar los 19 millones.
Además, dentro de las medidas de
estabilización se permitió flotar
libremente al rublo, lo que le llevó a
perder casi la mitad de su valor.
- "Millones de rusos perdieron sus ahorros
casi de la noche a la mañana,  el
consumo, que había sido el principal
motor en la última década,
ahora se desploma. El dinero se va del
país a causa de las sanciones y la
caída del precio del crudo".
Ya podéis imaginar el impacto que esto tuvo sobre la
capacidad de consumo y el bienestar de
la sociedad rusa.
- "Soy patriota de mi país y no estamos
luchando sólo por nosotros sino porque
estamos viendo qué futuro sólo va a
peor". Y es que, a pesar de
la imagen que muchas veces proyectan los
medios de comunicación,
Rusia es hoy uno de los países más
corruptos del mundo,
y el nivel de vida de sus ciudadanos es, por
lo general, bajo.
Esto no es que le tengamos manía a Rusia,
simplemente son los datos.
A pesar de todo ello, en los últimos
meses hemos visto señales positivas:
El kremlin ha decidido reducir un 30 por
ciento su gasto militar y en el
índice Doing Business, que mide la
facilidad para hacer negocios en un
país,
Rusia ha pasado del puesto 120 al 40,
haciendo que hoy sea más fácil hacer
negocios en Rusia que en Italia. De la
misma forma, en 2015 comenzó a operar la
Unión Económica Euroasiática, un
acuerdo de integración económica y
libre comercio con Armenia, Bielorrusia,
Kazajistán y Kirguizistán. Y este mismo
año también un tratado de libre
comercio con Vietnam.
Parece que la política económica de
Rusia está cambiando de rumbo.
- "Fíjense esto, una zona de libre comercio
entre la Unión Euroasiática y el
sudeste asiático puede aparecer en un
futuro cercano, afirmó el número uno del
Kremlin, Vladímir Putin.
En esta línea, el gobierno ruso se ha
embarcado en un programa de atracción
de inversiones con el que persigue que
las multinacionales trabajen en el país.
De hecho, en marzo 2016, las autoridades
rusas invitaron entre otros al
presidente de Inditex, Amancio Ortega, a que
traslade a Rusia una parte de la
producción del emporio encabezado por
Zara.
Por su parte la victoria de Trump
apunta a mejores relaciones y tal vez
al final de sanciones.
- "Entendemos que no será un camino fácil,
pero estamos listos para hacer nuestra
parte y haremos todo lo posible para
devolver las relaciones
ruso-estadounidenses a un camino estable y
sostenible de desarrollo".
Ahora bien, logran cambiar de rumbo no va
a ser una tarea fácil y es que este
país padece problemas estructurales severos.
Primero, el peso del estado es enorme
y hasta ahora la mayor parte de los
planes para privatizar las empresas
estatales han fracasado.
Está por ver que Putin sea capaz  y
quiera desmontar todas las instituciones
sobre las que ha asentado su poder
político. Y es que, la experiencia nos dice
que los proyectos políticos de desarrollo
están condenados al fracaso si no van
de la mano de la iniciativa privada y se
alienta el emprendimiento. Es lo que ha
ocurrido, por ejemplo, con Annapolis, una
nueva ciudad levantada de la nada para
albergar empresas tecnológicas donde
hay de todo
salvo empresas. Segundo, en Rusia todo
depende de Putin y eso genera poca o
ninguna seguridad jurídica.
¿Estarías dispuesto a invertir tu dinero
en un lugar donde te lo pueden quitar
mañana si el político de turno quiere?
- "NO,  NO, NO".
El líder ruso incluso acaba de poner en
marcha la Guardia Nacional, un cuerpo de
unos 25.000 hombres directamente bajo
sus órdenes.
Algo así como una guardia pretoriana
para consolidar su poder. Y la verdad es
que esto mucha confianza no genera.
Por otro lado, la demografía tan envejecida
que presenta Rusia, la corrupción
generalizada o el importante peso de los
oligarcas y grupos mafiosos
tampoco ayudan. En cualquier caso en
VisualPolitik esperamos que este
aparente cambio de rumbo se confirme y
entremos en una nueva era de
entendimiento, y también prosperidad
para el pueblo ruso. Porque de momento,
los resultados económicos de la era
Putin son bastante malos.
Vosotros qué pensáis ¿Creéis que Estados
Unidos debe tender la mano a Rusia?
Podéis pasaros por nuestro twitter y dejarnos
vuestro voto en la encuesta que hemos
abierto. Si nos están viendo y aún no
te has suscrito, no te preocupes, tiene
remedio. Puedes hacer clic ahora mismo en
este botón y empezar a formar parte de
esta pequeña gran familia. Un saludo y
hasta la próxima.